Julianna Rose moriello started her
acting career at the age of six when she
appeared in Sesame Street Fiesta in
1996. she went on to do the voice of
Ruby in the animated series about
bunnies Max and Ruby in 2002 raps are
best known role however is that of
Stephanie on the hit Nickelodeon series
LazyTown why did she stop acting and
what has she been doing since 2013 based
on the lack of details from official
sources any statement on a reason for
leaving show business would be
speculation what is clear however is
that moriello is now working as a
pediatric occupational therapist
according to her LinkedIn profile she
attended Columbia University vagelo
College of Physicians and surgeons and
is practicing in a clinic environment
whatever her reasons for leaving her old
career one would hope she is happy and
fulfilled with her new one I think this
year's gonna be different